so like the other day I went to my
barber and I was like can I get a
haircut and she said I'll cut your hair
but I'm not gonna cut your puff now
thank you and the nerdfighters may have
been wondering why I haven't made a
video in almost a week and a half it's
not because I got this hilariously bad
haircut I've never been embarrassed to
share my hilariously bad haircuts and
it's not because I've been dealing with
this gigantic pile of mulch either
although when that pile of mulch
initially arrived at my house it was
larger than my apartment in New York
nor is it because I've been fondling all
the awesome stuff that nerdfighters
brought us in Grand Rapids Michigan like
this ceramic cup that says dftba on it
and this book which is called scruffy
Teddy likes to play in your pants
scruffy Teddy you need a bath because
you are a dirty boy no Hank the reason I
haven't made a video in almost a week
and a half is that the Yeti and I have
made an extraordinary acquisition that
is unbelievably time-consuming
Hank without further ado allow me to
introduce you to bubbles the
nerdfighting puppy okay we don't
actually call them bubbles the
nerdfighting puppy I wanted to but the
Yeti was like it's gonna be weird when
we try to explain to people that he's a
boy but his name is bubbles the
nerdfighting puppy and then you know
everyone's gonna be like our
nerdfighters for nerds or against nerds
which is a stupid question I mean look
at my glasses no Hank we call this
adorable ball of fluff Willy okay I'm
just gonna keep talking well he does
cute stuff Willy's full name is fireball
Wilson Roberts which is a reference to
the first sentence of James Crummles
classic novel the last good kiss when I
finally caught up with Abraham Trey her
and he was drinking beer with an
alcoholic Bulldog named fireball Roberts
in a ramshackle joint just outside of
Sonoma California drinking the heart
right out of a fine spring afternoon now
Hank well he's a pretty adorable puppy
particularly when you're appreciating
him through the medium of video so that
you're not aware of the fact that he
always smells a little bit like his own
pee and I like Willie very much but I
have a message for all of the
nerdfighters out there who might be
considering getting a puppy oh my god it
is so hard
I mean Willie pretty much requires
constant attention and when he doesn't
get our full attention he makes this
noise that's like all the kittens in the
world have united with all the birds in
the world and they've gone to war with
monkeys and puppy-sized elephants it's
like Buddhist monks throat singing he's
doing seven notes at once also his
favorite thing in the world to do
to go outside and make you think he's
gonna pee and you think he's gonna pee
and you think he's gonna pee in that
uh-oh he just lay down so sometimes I
get pretty frustrated with him but they
don't be sitting across the room from me
and oh oh we'll do that thing where he
turns his head to the side it's so cute
and then I forgive him for everything so
Hank that's Willie I apologize for not
making more videos more often but as I'm
sure you can tell he's a bundle of joy
and a bundle of work however I am going
to make up for my lack of videos last
week by doing a punishment this week
that punishment I'm gonna do a video
every day this week this is going to
include two question Tuesdays so
nerdfighters please leave your questions
and comments also with every video this
week I'm going to give away one copy of
Paper Towns to a random commenter and
yes that includes this video for the
purposes of this punishment the week is
going to be Sunday Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday I'm taking Friday
off because as everyone knows Friday
night is the Sabbath if you're Jewish
which I'm not but I'm taking it off Hank
you'll see Willie Willie come on
cooperate quote no licking no Hank
you'll see Hank you'll see me tomorrow
Katherine happy birthday Willie say
happy birthday Katherine say oh he's
waving
happy birthday Catherine oh yeah did I
mention that he's a talking dog